[Music]
ed sheeran is
back with fangs the 30 year old singer
released his
highly anticipated single bad habits and
its accompanying music video on friday
featuring himself as an alter ego
vampire character
in the video ed is treating in his
ginger hair for a lighter blonder look
and fangs for teeth the singer embarks
on a wild night out alongside his crew
of ghouls all before morphing back to
his real self the next morning as the
sun
rises over him
[Music]
in a statement ed shared his sentiments
about dropping his new song and video
saying quote
feels great to be back with my new
single i wanted the video for bad habits
to play on the nature of habits in a
fantastical way
so i decided on vampires it was mega fun
getting into character
except for the heights that wasn't so
fun and his new single has total support
from his good friend
taylor swift who tweeted out ed has a
new song out and i legitimately cannot
get it out of my head
and this video stream by support bopped
to it
uncontrollably all summer hashtag bad
habits
i got nothing left to lose
music from ed has been a long time
coming bad habits marks his first
official release since his 2019
grammy-nominated number six
collaborations project album
the best thing is i uh make a living
making people happy which is
a wicked thing ed did drop his surprise
track afterglow back in december
and it came after he announced at the
end of 2019 that he was taking a break
from performing and music ahead of the
birth of his first child
lira who he welcomed in august with his
wife cherry seabourn
in a new interview on siriusxm hits one
on one the singer gushed about being a
new father
it is the best thing that's ever
happened to me i think there's so many
there's so many different sides and
shades to it that
you know some there's difficult days
there's amazing easy days there's
it's just a roller coaster of emotions i
know that sounds like uh
um a cliche thing to say but it's it's
it's amazing i love it during the
interview ed also revealed how
fatherhood has
changed the way he writes his music i'm
very structured with my day now so like
usually if i was in studio i would just
kind of work until it was done
i feel like with a kid you need a
structured
work day you can't be working until like
two o'clock in the morning you know she
has a nap structured she has a sleep
time structure in the bath time it's
just
i think that's the way the process has
changed while ed
isn't busy changing diapers next week he
will be appearing on the late late show
with james corden for a
week-long residency starting monday the
singer will be performing some of his
biggest hits each night kicking off with
a television debut of bad habits
but will also sit down with corden and
be featured in comedy segments
throughout the week
to you